on peut déjà rappelé le contexte mais
gagner harry et c'était baril il y a
deux ans donc la sortie d'un statut
n'est plus mis les pieds en angleterre
et du récent pour elle et lui ouais il
n'était plus revenu depuis les obsèques
de son grand-père on s'en souvient le
prince philippe c'était au mois d'avril
jeux de lumière sur ma propre fille
puissant ma fille a fait de la note est
donc et donc ils se sont juste là venant
vibe à 25 ans je
préfère vous écoute eh bien ils se sont
vus jeudi et 6 une date symbolique jeudi
à ce que j'adore marcher tout est
symbole je vais répéter je dis ça c'est
en quelque sorte le jour du pardon sont
arrivés je dis ça comme descendu du ciel
des nuages
sorte rameau d'olivier à la reine en ce
jour de pardon ils ont vraiment demandé
comment ça s'est passé c'est eux qui
sont venus comme ça direct c'est décidé
de venir y sont arrivés la veille appel
incruste ou valls a dit non il n'avait
prévenu personne en juin même pas
l'avant il
mais c'est un jet privé pour le coup de
dents c'est vrai je voudrais qu ils sont
issus louis son arrivée en jet si un
jour privée jet castex est intéressant
c'est qu'il tient
avec leurs services de sécurité parce
que vous savez leur sécurité pose
problème l'angleterre ne veut plus
subvenir aux frais lorsqu'ils sont sur
le territoire anglais puisque ne sont
plus altesse royale et n'étant plus
altesse royale ils n'ont plus droit à la
protection de scotland yard alors ils
sont venus avec leurs propres gardes du
corps 5 très exactement et le chef vous
rigolez le chef de ses gardes du corps
c'est l'ancien chef du garde du corps du
couple obama non
ils ont assisté à la messe selon la
traditionnelle messe du jeudi saint et
charles arena les abus ont à dire je n'y
étais pas ils
ont eu peur que la reine ne veulent pas
les voir non ils n'ont pas eu peur que
non mais elle savait qu'ils allaient
venir à l'élan et loyers quoi ils
doivent rire mais voilà qu'elle se
réjouissait de les revoir ils y seraient
deux semaines oui ça serait aller un peu
les deux
il avait 2 a revu alti fils arrive dans
le salon vert du château de windsor
royal lors ils se donnent rendez-vous
jackson hole château haut niveau on se
retrouve dans le salon d'air dans une
heure il
a vu les pièces donc quand même il ya
mille pièces dans le château windsor
lieu de faire une en face de chaque
mois et 10 mois et donc
est ce qu il a vu qu'il n'a pas vu
d'abord sa grand mère tout seul il a vu
direct et que sa meuf il l'avait direct
avec médias et non juste aquilani
il est requis qu'il veut pas voir sa
grand mère d'abord tout seul lui parler
après ramène sa meuf qui dira tout ce
qui n'est pas sous la coupe de megan
arrête un peu ça
analystes et moi je te dis
oui
j'échange au moins avec ma grand mère ma
grand mère tante adepte et après je
ramène ma meuf qui vient comme un canard
ex l'amf mais ferme ta gueule
non mais harry mozilla c'est quoi ça a
été ok alors qu'est-ce qu'ils sont 10
vous pensez que j'étais à l'entretien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors que
ces sujets pour nous dire qu'ils sont
vus dans le salon vert tout ça pour dire
que si ils reviennent croyez moi ils
vont continuer à revenir et ou parce que
la saison et d'enchaîner on avait une
douzaine le fameux contrat 100 millions
de dollars qu'ils ont signé avec netflix
et spotify est en train de se barrer
jura la vitesse de l'éclair pourquoi
actuellement ils sont à la haye ils font
les images vous savez aux pays bas c'est
cette fameuse manifestation qui a créé
le prince harry pour l'est les malades
de guerre en quelque sorte les
handicapés de guerre et netflix a apposé
cinq caméras qui les suivent en
permanence alors pour réaliser en
documentaire sur pourquoi ont-ils a posé
ses caméras parce que vouloir maintenant
ils n'ont rien foutu
100 millions de dollars mais ils n'ont
absolument rien au tennis et sa patte de
drôle de loustic n'ont pas franchement
oui s'ils vont me dire tout ça parce que
je pense que lors il a escaladé elle a
dit oui elle valait reprendront bah je
sais pas si vraiment elle a dit oui mais
en tout cas apparemment elle a tout fait
pour qu'il soit présent et lors du
jubilé on n'avait pas vu leur père leur
père ne peut apercevoir le prince
albert ils ont des chars la pression
dans l'autre c'est giardini je crois
c'est pas gentil ça mais je sais mais
c'est ce qu'ils disent c'est vrai ou pas
solide soupçonne à apprendre à faire une
guerre
la reine avait des cheveux qui virait
légèrement sur leur route ça va ça moi
aussi qu'est ce qui a interpellé c'est
qu'ils ont été déroutés
rouschop mort de sa fille ont qu'ils
occupent ça veut donc bien dire qu'ils
ont l'intention de revenir à londres
allez voir ils vont bientôt revenir au
bal a donc
salué la foule au balcon moi je me
retrouve à devoir je pense que c'est
moins d'eau moins de 3 la semaine
dernière sur
ngc loué la foule au balcon comme est ce
que les anglais vont le lui pardonner
parade alors justement mais médiane
merkel est terrible d'un point de vue
image et stratégie et qu'est ce qu'on
dit c'est que certes elle a revu harry
et mégane men a reçu une et deux
petits-enfants non elle n'a pas déjà
falloir saatchi est limitée par mantes
et
minimes est venu à eli lilly ont dit qu
elle met réserve quelque sorte pour le
jubilé c'est qu'elle est déjà en train
de leur apprendre à saluer ah ouais ça
si tu es désormais tous les états qu'ils
soient trop américanisé les anglais
attendent des petits princes en quelques
softs qui va compter c'est des petits
comme dans la série les chroniques de
britten
russes à la syrie c'est un merveilleux
week end de pâques pour ceux qui suivent
les monarchies sont nombreux pourquoi
parce que certes il ya eu c'est de
réconciliation incroyable à monaco et à
leur tour de chant
un
dossier je sais que tu es très content
elle est revenue sur le rocher un
et ça y avait que albert c'est ça va
bien
apparemment ça va bien mieux puisque
deux clichés hyper glamour ont été
envoyés à dans les rédactions du monde
entier et c'est très important parce que
ce sont les deux monarchies emblématique
année vous y sort et les grimaldi à
monaco
d'accord
pour la première fois depuis deux ans et
demi le prince harry et meghan markle
ont rendu visite à la reine elizabeth
mardi dernier la rencontre ait lieu au
château de windsor la résidence
principale de la reine à seulement
quelques jours de son 96e anniversaire
le prince harry 37 ans et meghan markle
40 ans n'étaient plus venus ensemble
oreo munie depuis leur mise en retrait
fracassante de la famille royale en 2020
ils vivent désormais en californie selon
les médias britanniques arie mégane ont
également rencontré le prince charles
pendant cette escale au web
pour les giboulées
[Rires]
c'est d'autant plus symbolique ce jour
là bas la petite lili bêtes à plumes
dont la fille ou 2 harry et mégane pas
le diminutif du prénom d'elisabeth elle
aura donc deux ans l'année prochaine et
elle fête son anniversaire le 4 juin
ce sera le choc
pour le journal cite des berges du lac
la jarre chimie si la russie doit
pas tout connais même pas l'âge de
vérifier mais bon tu viens tu as un
petit bo proxy bâtir tout ça vous chante
bon alors donc mégane et harry voilà bon
se réconcilier avec l'arrêt nord ça tu
veux je te dise franchement j'avais très
envie de le savoir plaisir pour la reine
insécables ça fait plaisir pour tout le
monde ça fait plaisir pour le royaume
uni moi je suis un fou d'angleterre mais
à woods anglet c est sûr c'est son
anniversaire dans trois jours qui a la
reine oui je suis à 16 ans je sécurité
habiter
cadeaux signés mort
[Rires]